I almost forgot to ask you about China
so both historically we talked about the
Soviet Union but what lessons do you
draw from the implementation of
socialism communism in maoist China and
modern China what is what's the good and
the bad well I think it's very similar
um to the Soviet case and that socialism
came to China
um
through not a base of organized workers
and then in a capitalist country at a
certain level development and so on but
it came through the countryside and in
conditions of Civil War
Strife your Japanese invasion and
whatever else and Mao built his base in
the peasantry I then came down to the
city to govern and try to build the base
and rule over uh workers so it was kind
of an inversion of classic socialist
Theory
now the same thing that I said before
about Stalin and assessing the Soviet
Union has to apply here because
obviously you know I oppose
authoritarianism and you know I
obviously all sorts of moral con
condemnations I I sh I should do but to
look at what the Chinese Communist Party
actually accomplished
I think we kind of need to take a step
backwards from our moral opposition to
the means in which they accomplish it
and just look at it developmentally
China benefited greatly from the
Communist party's implementation of
basic education and Healthcare
um so in a lot of China you had one of
the conditions of women were absolutely
terrible there was still foot binding
and all sorts of like terrible backward
um practice
um you had a huge vast majority of the
population that was illiterate without
any access to basic education and you
had no um Health Access especially on
the countryside so those are the three
good things that that China did improve
the status of women
um get everyone into primary education
and improve the lot of Health Care
besides for that
um their agricultural campaign was a
failure just like stones for many of the
same reasons I mentioned before
um be great leap forward and uh crash
industrialization didn't really work
either
um in a way is trying to better than
India or other
countries that that didn't have the
basic education and the strong State
Authority and and
um the the health improvements and
whatever
I think maybe but I think that's why we
need to sometimes go beyond just
economic measures of success
because if you told me tomorrow the U.S
will grow at three percent if we
maintain democracy but it'll grow at
eight nine percent everyone be wealthier
if we move to some sort of authoritarian
government I think
you're asking the wrong question if
we're going to make your decision based
on growth right because it has to be
based on some sort of you know principle
but the same Dynamic of
from the beginning the Chinese Communist
Party ruling over people emerging from
the outside through armed conflicts and
ruling over
um ordinary Chinese people have
continued
since then Xiao paying the policies have
been better economically and often at
times not always the technocratic
governance has been you know quite good
but that doesn't mean that the party has
a democratic mandate or or has the
should have the right to govern as they
see as they see fit because clearly you
know it doesn't have that mandate and
swats of the country or in places like
Hong Kong or or elsewhere
um but to me
um
nothing the Chinese Communist Party does
has anything to do with socialism I
think even by their own definition today
it really doesn't
um it's a sort of nationalist
authoritarian developmental state that
has done some good things to improve the
living standards of the Chinese people
other things that were counterproductive
and
um you know as a Democratic Socialist
you know I I certainly don't support
that state but I also hope that the US
and Biden will find a way to avoid
um you know intense rivalry and
competition economically spilling over
into something worse from a Democratic
Socialist perspective
what's one policy or one or two ways you
could fix if you could fix China if you
took over China what would you like to
see change well the Democratic part
comes before the Socialist part so I
would say there needs to be multi-party
elections in China and
um State censorship and control over the
press in other words needs to be be done
with as far as their immediate economic
um policy I think the idea of
maintaining
um strong State control of certain you
know commanding Heights to the economy
while liberalizing other spheres has
done quite well in China's case lifting
people out of poverty
um but again you know there's something
really lost in the society even if it's
getting wealthier if you're a great
you know if Ordinary People don't have
the ability to
um participate in dissent
um freely and the Chinese authorities
have allowed some you know it's not
North Korea it's not a totally
totalitarian state there's been
workplace protests have been all sorts
of anti-corrupt local anti-corruption
protests and things like that but it's
up the government decides what's
permitted and what's not at what
particular moment and uh I think the
long run
um even if it can survive
[Music]
um
there's there's a better way to do
things which is quite simply
um a democracy
the thing is though the lessons of
history that China is looking at this is
dark aspect
um so building on top of the fact that
it seems like under Stalin and undermau
understand the Soviet Union and under
Mao China has seen a lot of economic
growth
and then one dark aspect of that
while under the Great Leap Forward you
have you know upwards of 70 million
people dead
today I think there's a large number of
people who admire Stalin and admire Mao
what they admire is the stability and
the strong leadership so in this there's
a lot of people who miss the Soviet
Union right the reason why they miss it
is that it was a system they knew it
provided the basics of their livelihood
uh then afterwards like look at Russia
in the 90s people were in chaos and the
Communist party was had a huge amount of
support democratically
anti-democratic measures had to be taken
ironically against the Communist Party
um to keep it from regaining more of a
foothold in in Russia
but
we don't need that trade-off you know we
could have a form of
um imagine if Russia went to a system
closer to social democracy
that maintained
um the stability that people wanted the
welfare state that people wanted but
restructure the economy and not a shock
way but in a way that that made sense
and that Ordinary People felt ownership
of instead of just oligarchs who were
former Communist Party bureaucracy just
dividing up the country for themselves
um I think the same thing in China like
first of all certainly from
the West
um
you know the US government and people in
the U.S should have you know have no say
over what should happen in China right
the the Chinese Communist party has more
authentic authentic Authority than any
of us do in the country but
you know I think that the fears of its
ability that a lot of Chinese people
have why I would imagine that even in a
democratic election the uh Communist
Party might have uh majority support
is because they fear the unknown they
fear collapse that was one of the big
lessons of the the Soviet collapse right
do you want trying to divide it into
five six
States you know do you want um economic
turmoil do you want Mass immediate
privatization do you want whatever
welfare state you have
um destroyed and so on
I think people are right to have those
fears but there's a different route
towards democratization that maintains
stability right there's different routes
that you could that you could have
um you know democracy not not every
country had to go down the route of
Yugoslavia and the USSR and and so on